how did you first hear that bill cosby
was going to be released oh
this morning when i got up and rolled
out of bed
uh my friend stephen lenigen he called
he
he gave me a telephone call and he told
me
he said i have some bad news and i was
bracing for like you know a hurricane or
something and he was like
you know cosby's out of prison and i was
so i felt i felt like
first of all really so angry
so angry uh
and second i felt like i was kicked in
the stomach by
in my abdomen by some psychic blow what
do you
you say you felt like you were kicked in
your stomach but
you know they're saying this is a
procedural
issue and that's why he was released how
do you feel about that
i'm angry i'm angry they let him out
over a procedural that's
that's basically all i have to say i
can't get into the legalese of
about it i can only speak for my heart
and say
that the statute of limitations is not
fair
it's not it's it's it's just not fair
there are people who are they're falling
on both sides but some people are
rejoicing and saying he deserve you know
it's it's only fair that he gets out
what do you say to those people
oh i say to those people you have not
been raped by them i
i was raped by bill cosby and i know
that uh it changed my life forever
and that's why my heart goes out to all
the women
that started me too after i first came
out on the on your show
it was it's it's i i just think people
are ignorant
you